こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
こんにちは管理人の大地です
3億円のお家にお化け屋敷作ってみたー
第3もうすでに見られているということで
僕はもう全部知ってますかもう設営まで
はいなんか昨日あたりずっとやられてた
みたいなんですけどそう2日間かけて約
24時間かけて作ってましたねお化け屋敷
をお化け屋敷よこの家にこの家に200万
かけて200万かけてこれ企画に出したの
は僕なんですよ
僕がなんか
夏だし
寒気のうちお化け屋敷とか作ったらどう
ですかねみたいな感じで言ってたら本当に
できるみたいな
感じになりまして
実際に気づいたらもう僕は何も知らないん
ですけどももう今家の中にお化けシーが
あるということで
怖いですね富士急の戦慄迷宮じゃないです
か
もしかしたら
超えちゃったかもしれないです
すげえ
凝ってるなっていう
家に作るクオリティではないお化け屋敷が
今あるというかまさに3億円なのに
ふさわしいお化け屋敷ができているという
ことで間違いないと思います
じゃあ行ってきます
行ってきます行ってらっしゃい
[音楽]
あマジかマジかこれオレンジか
これ俺んちかこれ俺マジかちょっと待って
待って待って動けない
えどここれ下かな
[音楽]
シンプルに怖い
無理
[音楽]
えなんか変わるか感じますけどここは
殺人鬼の家だもうすぐ帰ってくる
ごめんなさいちょっと待って
はいやばいちょっと待って
[音楽]
すいませんえっと
ロッカに隠れろ
無理無理無理
誰かい
[音楽]
なんで隠れるの
あー
あーんね
えやばい
腰抜けたまずい
あーごめんなさいごめんなさいマジで
とっても
ごめんなさい
待ってもうやばいもう普通にやばい
ごめんなさいもうやばいっす
やばいもう無理ですこれ
俺めくらなきゃいけないってことをしたら
やばい
失礼しますやばい
次出てきたのにダメです
[音楽]
本当にごめんなさい
何してるんですか何これ
[音楽]
やばいやばい
やばい
[音楽]
やばい怖いうわ臓器コミュニティ
ガイドライ
スバルで座る感じ
[音楽]
一応
誰でもいけるお化け屋敷だから
常識の範囲内なんだよ
ガッチリ触れられましたはいというわけで
お化け屋敷こちらになりますね2階の広い
スペースですねちょっと僕先1回経験した
ので実際にちょっとどういう仕掛けができ
てるのか
ナイチこの実験台にして見ていきたいと
思います
お願いしますお願いしますまずはいそう
いう感じで
[音楽]
最初の関門がこちらですねここが殺人鬼の
家だもうすぐ帰ってくる早くロッカーに
かけろというわけでまず六花に隠られる
だけではいけないということですねこれ
選ぶみたいな感じで
開かないと
そっちはちょっとなるほど
でこれ入ると
[音楽]
はい
ロッカーをここで
[拍手]
これマジで怖い
うわー
ロッカー倒されるんだ
[音楽]
このまたファーストステップですねはい
そして次はこちらですね
[拍手]
これが
床がなんかブニャブルしてるステージです
ね今何かとこう来て
[音楽]
ここですね
ここやばいねもうなんか買おうかこれ
すごいよもう顔だらけよそして
次どしんがこちらですね
[音楽]
殺人鬼がメイドさんを
大丈夫ですか大丈夫ですかこれ本当おちに
怒ってることがこれ
俺んちかこれ
[音楽]
逃げて逃げてこっち突破したら次がこちら
ですねなんか
幕で
スカートだけに見えるんですよねここ
これ
怖いね
行ってみましょうか
[音楽]
いや怖
い
[拍手]
次がこちらがなんか食卓みたいな感じです
ね出してお願いしますはいまず座らせられ
てあ
他の方もいらっしゃいました
これまずオレンジなのこれ
YouTubeに映るのかどうかってとこ
ですよこれ大さんが来ました
横流し
ろうそく
うわ
ぁここでメイドさんが机の下から
逃げてと呼んでくれるというわけですね
メイドさんから教えてもらった秘密の通路
で抜け出そうという感じになります
後ろから来てます
よしこれで
[拍手]
殺人鬼がまた来て
いや
怖え
皆さんが逃げて逃げてって
これで
ゴールになりました
よというわけで
せっかくなのでいろんな後輩や
仲間たちに地獄のようなお化け屋敷を
楽しんでもらいましたみんなは何も知ら
ないからね
素敵な冒険の旅に決めるから行くわけだ
冒険のためです
わかりました
ハッピーでそうだってハッピーをもう
涙なしが見えません
涙ちょっと
顔暗いかもしれないのに
どこ行けばいいですかよしよしよし
え何何何
え
いきます
[音楽]
うわードアだどうはどうなになにここは
殺人鬼の家だもうすぐ帰ってくる早く6巻
に隠れよ
[音楽]
どういうこと
やばいやばいやばいやばい
えーやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいってやばい
やばい何やばいやばいやばい
[音楽]
待って待って待って待って
行けないや
[音楽]
あすごい
近くね
ここですねここここ
はいわかりました
失礼します
はいありがとうございます
で
電気忘れちゃったちょっと
歩けないんだけどちょっと
[音楽]
待ってちょっと待ってちょっと
[拍手]
待って
どうでしたか
怖すぎる本当に苦手夏の思い出
夏の思い出
いやー1番
楽しいね
これ以上
いきますよお願いします
自分の世界へようこそ
[音楽]
最悪だー最悪だ
何
どっか
マジでやだ
開かないしろっか
[音楽]
ロッカー開かないし
何
[音楽]
やめてください
[拍手]
[音楽]
うわーもう怖い怖い怖い怖い
やばいって
怖い怖い怖い怖い
うわーもう最悪だ
[音楽]
お疲れ様でした
死んだかと思ったどうしたこれはやりすぎ
さんにはプラネタリウムゾーンを楽しんで
もらおうと思うんですけど暗いんで
暗いこれで顔照らしてもらいながら言って
くれる動画
[音楽]
夏の素敵な思い出ぜひ作って下さいマジ
怖いえちょっと待って
本当に
一緒に行きましょう
[音楽]
無理だ遊園地
待って
[音楽]
ここは殺人鬼の家だもうすぐ帰ってくる
早くロッカ
[音楽]
に確認
取れれ
横になってきて
[音楽]
ごめんなさいごめんなさいあー
ごめんなさい
[音楽]
もう無理です
いやもうマジで
[音楽]
マジで
僕無理なんですって本当に
言うこと聞いてくださいあ
ごめんなさいごめんなさいごめんなさい
ごめんなさい
ごめんなさいごめんなさい
[音楽]
無理だ
すいません
もう何でもしますから
仲間に入れてくださいこのままでいて
ください
[音楽]
ちょっともうな
いろいろありすぎじゃん
待ってください
どうしたらいいですか
ここですか
[音楽]
仲間になったみたいだ
食べている
[音楽]
お肉が
僕も
取り寄せられましたあー
食べます
僕も
ごめんなさい
[音楽]
ごめんなさいごめんなさいごめんなさい
逃げます
[音楽]
[笑い]
めちゃめちゃ軽い気持ちで来たもう二度と
来ないですか
まさか
キャバクラ好きですか
キャバクラ行ったことね一緒に行ったじゃ
ないですか1回だけじゃん
なんと
家の中に
キャバクラ作っちゃいました
[拍手]
[音楽]
はい楽しんできてくださいはいいっ
てらっしゃい行ってきますいっ
てらっしゃい
何
何何
進めばいいんすよね
えっこうはなんやこれ
入っていいから
え
っ
動いてるなんか
何
ここは殺人鬼の
鬼の家だもうすぐ帰ってくる早く
[音楽]
[拍手]
本当に何してんの
[音楽]
何
持ってるんですかこれ
待ってこんなの渡してないということで
サボテンの家にお化け屋敷作ってみたでし
た
[音楽]
B様バケーション